oh come on come on come on come on get
it
get it yes where is that eddie hall
standing over here
come on keep moving keep moving get up
get it dark don't use
is a one-of-a-kind show get off i'm
eddie hall will strongest man 2017.
these guys have been through the
struggles all different shapes all
different sizes
they're coming to me looking to change
their lives for the better
you've seen transformations but you
haven't seen transformations like this
or you're gonna absolutely
feast out of these guys
my name is sam parcell i'm a sales
executive in mayfair my whole body has
gone by the wayside
unfortunately my dad passed away when i
was quite young
a massive heart attack and it was a
really really horrible thing so i need
to be fit and healthy and i need to be
beasted
[Music]
[Laughter]
you've come to me just to get get
motivated get beastie can we
put you through a number of tests yeah
six tests to be exact you're gonna test
your strength
your agility your endurance i want you
to meet luke
and chris all right these two are my
right and left hand men
[Music]
we're gonna do body fats before we begin
actually
where are we 1 30 fat 130
right first of the six tests is a max
deadlift
[Music]
come on relax yes finish it
down
[Music]
is
right let's get serious
up come on come on come on come on get
in
get it yes
that's it one five
come on what failed you son
guardian massively yeah one
two one come on
15 seconds down
[Music]
big drive big drive come on come on
yeah so hopefully we can look back in
six weeks yeah and we could even laugh
at it
exactly right now right
mate you've been absolutely phenomenal
but i feel as i'm gonna be even more
impressed in six weeks time i really
like sam i thought he was a super nice
guy i feel as though
sam is going to go away and put the work
in he's strong so he's got a great base
to work on we just want to send him away
get those bases up even more and then
get the belly fat down and i think he's
going to come back he's going to look
absolutely phenomenal
right i've got a i like you for some
chicken wings right now for some reason
so
i'm starving good job geez guys
morning also this is my first post first
morning had a look at the
diet which is uh interesting so it's
gonna be bland but it's gonna
certainly do the trick
[Music]
evening all end of day two today gym
today was awesome
had a really good gym session day off
today meal number three
i'm just gonna put some oats in water
and then in the microwave ultimate lazy
in a coffee shop this morning and saw
all the nicest cakes and pastries in the
world i'm not having that
that's not what i get
last day of the first week i think i've
done really well
i've noticed that clothes are starting
to fit better
day 11 staff canteen i am eating chicken
and green stuff
this is another fun meal i put pepper on
it
i don't care what luke or chris says i'm
putting pepper on it now i've woken up
with flu or a cold or something and i
feel
absolutely horrific come up to the end
of the second week
so a third of the way through still
two-thirds to go
it's only the end of week two but please
don't give up
i'm sending luke and chris over to check
on you so make sure you keep smashing it
well done and keep being awesome
hey chris good afternoon hello sir you
look really well mate
oh cheers thanks very
i've been with sam for five years we got
married
two months ago he's very regimented but
i can't believe
after having so much time out of the gym
and doing that
strength stuff how much how strong i've
got in the two and a half weeks so
quickly how
mood's been i've experienced sitting on
several
different types of diets and regimes
one where you didn't eat any solids for
a long long time i'd say this was
probably
the best one in terms of getting results
you know the difference is i've had to
throw two suits away this is my favorite
jumper
and i've been able to fit into it for a
very long time i've always liked
good another half to go yep massive
changes already
we just think you've got to set your
shirt off in front of the world's
strongest man and
do some stuff to impress him we're kind
of getting to the halfway point
and it was an amazing sort of pick up
and uh sort of give me the
encouragement i really really needed
[Music]
so just finished a horrible gym session
look what my other half
was asking me to go and get a cheeky
bugger and she asked me to go get some
sweets
[Music]
sam how are you doing bro hey yeah
how's it going initial impressions
it looks like you've lost some weight
around your face yeah yeah definitely
way everywhere man so far i think just
over 10 kilos
10 kilos what do you do chop
off that's impressive man you're in a
better mood because you've lost the
weight more energy yeah
bags very philippines i'm going down the
gym and enjoying it and loving it
no sam i i don't need to say much man
you're doing fantastic
i can't wait to see in a few weeks and
see what else you've knocked off keep it
up buddy
[Music]
i'm super impressed with sam i mean he's
done really well at this stage but
this is where people get complacent
think to himself oh you know i can have
a kebab i can have a curry will he do
well
chances are yes but there's a little bit
of skepticism there
along the way a lot of people have been
sort of saying you know well done you've
done amazingly it's
you know you can see the difference but
no one's really ever asked me
why i'm doing it it was watching myself
and seeing myself become
everything i said i would never ever do
my father passed away
when i was when i was young and the way
i was watching him
eat drink he smoked wasn't into
exercise or anything i just i was so you
know it's such a sad thing
to see someone who's supposed to look up
to let it all go thinking about it is
vital that i i did something like this
um you know you can't live forever like
this but what it's done is put
everything into perspective
how has you been getting on with
everything yeah it's been doing really
well i think it's been tough
but uh it's definitely done better than
i was expecting
the mood swings weren't as bad as i was
expecting either
we want to have a family and he wants to
be able to
do everything and be able to like run
around with kids i think that's why he
sees it as
like a lifelong change now rather than
just six weeks yeah
about to go and meet eddie meet the guys
being a little bit nervous a little bit
apprehensive
hey yeah how's it going mate you look
great thanks got your top off i can see
you really cutting the chest
how much weight have you lost in total
then um i think was it
12 just over 12 feet i mean it's over 12
12 kilo
in six weeks now last time we felt as
though
your shoulder press was your weakest
point you knew very well was it less
than 10 reps if you remember
is it five here comes your nemesis mate
five six
seven
push
that's incredible the number's
ridiculous it's more than tripled
absolutely incredible absolutely
incredible really impressed
one more thing we need we did the before
picture
and i said to you in the after picture i
want to see some abs have you got abs
not quite no did you put your abs in the
workout
it's amazing when you see them side by
side
it's a massive difference it's a huge
difference absolutely incredible
sam you should be super proud it's the
most
incredible experience and i feel so
privileged to have got to do it i think
my dad would be
incredibly proud of what i've achieved
after what
he went through and the way it went down
for him if he was here now he
would be telling me i was doing exactly
the right thing you've all done amazing
but the biggest well done goes to you
sam
you have officially been beasted
you